- The Democrats are definitely
not as screwy as we are,
and I think they're not
screwy at all actually
in the Democratic Party.
They raise money in a
very disciplined way.
And you know, they do
have their little tiffs,
personality tiffs between
the squad and Nancy Pelosi.
But overall, I think
they're very disciplined.
And now, for the first couple
of years I was at the RNC,
we would be cheering, "Rah rah,"
because we raised more money
into the RNC than the DNC
raises into the DNC.
And they're quietly laughing,
because they raised 10 times
as much money as we do,
but they raised it into
the NAACP, and the ACLU,
and the Michigan Welfare
Rights Association,
and La Raza, and
La Familia Vota.
Those five organizations
are organizations that I'm
up against in court right now
for election litigation,
it is not the DNC.
They have dark
money organizations
that influence our elections,
and help pick right
wing candidates in
moderate districts.
And so that we just
like, we are cooked.
We're thinking,
"Great, we selected
this great conservative
candidate."
That candidate can't
win in that state,
and so we're just like not
even talking about that.
So their monetary ecosystem
is far superior to ours,
and they're very disciplined,
and we are not, and
we need to get smart.
(dramatic music)
- I'm Dave Rubin,
and joining me today
is the founder of
Dhillon Law Group,
an absolute free speech warrior.
I'm talking first team
all free speech warrior,
and now candidate
for the Republican
National Committee chair,
Harmeet Dhillon, Harmeet,
welcome back to
"The Rubin Report."
- Thanks for having me.
- I'm glad to have you, Harmeet,
and we haven't spoken in
a while, at least on air,
and I thought you would
be the perfect guest
to be our last guest of 2022,
because one of the main messages
that I'm always
pushing on this show
is that good people
have to get involved.
And just in the
last couple weeks,
you have thrown your
hat in the ring,
and you're getting involved.
So my first question, I
suppose is, are you nuts?
- (chuckling) Yeah, this
question has been asked of me
by several people who love me.
And you know,
(Dave laughing)
there come a few, I'm sure
Dave, you've had them,
where you were like, "Hey, let
me go start this new thing,"
or, "let me leave this
cozy thing I have,
and follow my dream."
I had that when I,
I've had that a few
times in my life,
and I kind of felt
struck by that.
So I, you know, discussed
it with my husband,
we prayed over it, and
you know, we decided yes,
you feel in your heart,
you have to stand
up and challenge
what's going on at the RNC,
because you cannot stand by and
just nod and have, you know,
another shrimp cocktail,
and pretend like everything
is going well, when it's not.
And so that's really, I
really felt compelled.
I've kind of felt that way
for the last couple
of years, in fact.
But, you know, after the
2020 election debacle,
President Trump endorsed
Ronna, Ronna McDaniel
for a third term.
And, you know, that
itself was something
that a lot of folks
thought, well,
maybe it was time for
new leadership then.
Not that it was her fault,
but when you are in charge,
and perhaps you don't, you
know, quite pivot and respond
to changing election laws and
other issues, and messaging,
maybe it's time for
a fresh approach.
Well, you know, we
didn't have that.
And so she did promise
in her last run
that she was going to have
a third and final term.
And then suddenly, surprisingly,
she said she's gonna
run for a fourth term.
And so I said, "Wait a
minute, we have not won,
in what I call the
definition of winning,
in three successive
election cycles."
I mean, here in California,
2018 was a wipe out.
We had a, it was
like we lost half.
2020, we lost the White
House, we lost the House.
We barely clung to the Senate.
2022, we're barely
clinging to the House,
such that there is
a leadership race
that has conservative
members of Congress
calling each other names
on Twitter, that's,
and airing their dirty
laundry out in public.
And we're saying,
"Yeah, let's sign up
for another two years of this,
and another election cycle."
America can't afford
for us to continue
to be behind the eight ball,
and playing catch
up with Democrats.
We just can't.
And so if nothing changes,
we are gonna expect
the same thing.
And I, for one, don't
wanna be sitting here
twiddling my thumbs while,
we're 10, 20 years
behind the Democrats.
And we don't have to
be, because you know,
Dave, you know, there's so
much energy in our movement,
there's so many smart,
young and middle-aged people
outside D.C., people who
are social media savants,
people who are fluent
with the culture,
people who get that
the base of our party
has shifted from NeoCon
cold war warriors,
and Chamber of
Commerce messaging,
and tax cuts for the rich,
to blue collar workers
and young people
who are energized
about the future,
and wanna have a
home and a family.
We are out of touch, and I
don't think we need to be.
So I'm here to bring
us back into touch,
and have that attempt
to reform the RNC
into fitting what the
base of the party is.
- Okay, so I wanna
unpack all that,
including some of the
Republican in-fighting,
and everything else that
you touched on there.
But before we do all of that,
for anyone in my audience
that hasn't seen you
on the show before,
or isn't that familiar,
could we do a little
Harmeet 101 real quick?
Why did I describe you
as a free speech warrior?
- Well, I've been doing
free speech litigation
literally since
before I was a lawyer.
I went to Dartmouth at age 16.
I grew up in rural
North Carolina.
And at Dartmouth, I
became the editor-in-chief
of the famous "Dartmouth
Review" newspaper
that Dinesh D'Souza, Laura
Ingraham, and many, you know,
now famous people on the
right have been part of.
And during that time,
three of my colleagues
were actually kicked
out of Dartmouth
for something they
wrote about a professor.
And so back in the day, the
American Civil Liberties Union
used to actually care
about free speech,
and they sent us a lawyer
who helped us sue Dartmouth.
So at the age of 19,
I was on "60 Minutes"
talking about free speech
issues on American campuses.
We won, my friends
got reinstated,
set me off of my pre-med
course into a career in law.
And so ever since I
graduated from law school,
now almost 30 years ago,
I've been working on
issues of liberty.
And since I started
my own law firm,
we have focused a lot
on free speech issues
in virtually every context,
but we're well
known for our work
in social media censorship.
I've sued Twitter a couple
of times, three times.
We're, you know,
just representing
half of conservative
social media.
You know, we represent reporters
who are sued by politicians.
We represented "The
Daily Wire" in litigation
in the United States
Supreme Court.
And, you know, Project Veritas,
we've stood up for
their rights in court.
And so it's a real honor,
because it's really
the epitome for me.
The First Amendment
is first for a reason,
and it's something so special,
compared to the
rest of the world,
even the English speaking world.
They don't have a First
Amendment, we have that.
And so it's a passion
to do that work,
and probably 1/3 of the lawyers
at my 22-lawyer firm do that
work, and it's really exciting.
- Yeah, and I wanna give
you a little credit publicly
that I've given you privately,
which is that over the years,
when I've had a lot of crazy
hit pieces written about me,
I've called you a couple times,
particularly the one with
"The New York Times,"
when they basically
on the cover said
I'm the head of the alt-right.
And I was like, you know, "Can
I sue them, and whatever?"
And you calmly explained to me
that unfortunately in
the world we live in,
even with our libel and
slander laws, like it's tough,
it's tough, and it'll
probably cost you
way more than it'll cost
this giant corporation.
So you've talked me off
the ledge once or twice,
so I owe you for that.
- Yeah, absolutely,
and look, to skip away-
- Now I don't care, for the
record, they keep doing it,
and it's like, now it's
kind of funny to me,
but years ago-
- Now, you know what?
- Yeah?
- You're bigger than them,
and so what, you know.
So that, you know,
like, believe me,
in fact the RNC has been
peddling hit pieces about me,
and it's very upsetting.
But luckily I'm
surrounded by calm people,
who are like, "The truth
is there, you'll prevail."
And so it's all good.
But, you know,
to leave a job that I'm
very passionate about,
two jobs, I also
started a non-profit,
it's people who can't
afford or, you know,
for other reasons, they need
pro bono legal help for free,
and that is a very,
you know, active
nonprofit center for
American liberty.
We represent children
who are targeted
by transgender groomers.
We represent people
in free speech issues.
We represent a host of
other civil rights issues.
And to leave that
in my law firm,
which does be
favorite part of law,
that most lawyers would kill
to be able to do all day,
and get paid for it, that's
how passionate I feel
about this RNC thing.
I mean, I love my job
right now, I love my jobs,
but I love America
more than that.
And I think that we're
just driving this thing
off a cliff here, and
we can't afford it.
So nobody else stepped
up, so I stepped up.
I mean, Lee Zeldin
talked about it,
but ultimately didn't wanna
take on the challenge,
'cause it is a challenge,
and I stepped up, so.
I'm gonna see it through.
- All right, so before we get
into all of that nitty gritty
that you mentioned earlier,
just a little bit more
on the big tech stuff
and free speech,
'cause obviously we're seeing
all of the Twitter files
dumping right now.
At the same time, we're also
seeing the mainstream media,
or the corporate press,
whatever you wanna call them,
we're seeing them
completely ignore it.
So our divergence
between the people
that believe one thing,
and the people that
believe another thing,
is just getting wider
and wider and wider.
Do you think anything
will actually come
out of these leaks?
I mean, beyond the fact that
a certain amount of people
will wake up, do you think that
there will be legal action,
either against the
U.S. government,
or further action
against Twitter?
And does that then push
things down so that, you know,
down the road, so that YouTube,
and Google, and Facebook,
and everybody else
might start getting looked at
in a different way as well?
- Well, there is action
against the U.S. government,
Merrick Schmidt, attorney
general and some others
are filing suit.
Before the Twitter
files came out,
my law firm and the Center
for American Liberty
sued Twitter and a
host of other parties,
including California Secretary
of State for this very thing.
And they, it was revealed
after the 2020 election,
that California, my
government, right,
which I pay a lot of taxes to,
was using those tax dollars.
Enemies, one of the
enemies is our client,
Rogan O'Handley, AKA DC Draino,
who was just reinstated
on Twitter last week.
Our lawsuit is ongoing.
That kind of
litigation is ongoing,
but the courts are not
receptive to it at this time.
You know, we lost that
case in the district court.
We argued in the Ninth Circuit,
you win or lose based
on the perspective
of the judges who are
on the court, frankly.
So what is needed, in my opinion
to really reform this situation,
is for Republicans
to win elections.
Republicans have
to win elections,
and it has to be the
right Republicans.
If you actually had the,
you know, out of touch crew,
who's in the Republican
Congress and Senate right now,
those were the same people
who were in the Republican
Congress and Senate
when we had the White
House in 2017 and 2018,
those were the leaders.
They did nothing to address
social media censorship.
We need to elect new and
better Republicans who get it.
We need to reform Communications
Decency Act section 230,
to not allow
basically a free pass
to all kinds of torts
and contract violations
that courts are ignoring
under the ages of 230.
And then we need to
create, in my opinion,
of social media users.
- What do you say to
the counterargument
on the 230 argument?
We've discussed it
a lot on the show,
that some people will say,
"Well, if you take away
some of those protections,
that then you'll actually
hamper free speech,
because the platforms will feel
that they're more responsible,
and then they'll have
to go after everybody
to make sure everything's,
you know, clean or okay."
- Yeah, I'm not advocating
the removal of 230.
I don't agree with that.
There's a provision
of it that says
that social media companies
can remove content
that is quote unquote,
"Otherwise objectionable."
So it isn't in an
enumerated list.
They use that
otherwise objectionable
to say vaccine information
that's contrary to
what Fauci says.
They use that as an excuse
to censor things that they,
the social media company, want
to suppress or manipulate.
Or worse, as we're learning
through the Twitter files,
they let our government do
that without disclosing it.
No, I do not think
that was the meaning
of section 230 at all.
And Congress can
make that clear.
The law is old, 1996 law,
passed to actually protect
social media companies.
It's an out of control monster,
and one of the reasons that,
Dave, that you say that,
you know, there's sort of
a lack of responsiveness
by the mainstream
media on these issues,
the mainstream media has
actually been crippled
by dint of the social
media companies
having rights and privileges
to say and do
whatever they want.
Whereas the traditional media
doesn't have those
rights and privileges.
In a way, CDA 230
has really weaponized
the growth of these,
the unaccountability of these
big social media companies.
And so I think there are some
tweaks that could be done
without empowering
the government,
empowering the users.
There should be a social
media user's bill of rights
that says that if they
change the terms on you,
if they ban you or suppress you
for reasons that they did
not disclose in advance,
you have a right to sue them.
We have rights like that,
with respect to
pharmaceutical products,
products that blow up,
cars that don't work.
We have those rights
with commercial products.
This is a commercial product,
I'm paying to use Twitter,
I should have some rights
with respect to Twitter.
- So what would you
say, I've actually,
I know you do some work
obviously with Ron Coleman,
who's been on the
show many times,
and we discussed
this once on air,
if I was to find
out, for example,
that the government directly
had contacted Twitter
to take down the tweet that
I had back in July of 2021,
saying that vaccine
mandates were coming,
and vaccines were not
working, as promised,
et cetera, et cetera,
if I was to find out,
through these Twitter files
or whatever it might be,
that that actually it was
because of a government agent
telling Twitter to take it down,
what is the reward for someone,
other than that maybe the
government would acknowledge it,
can you sue the government?
Like, can you be like, "Well,
I want 10 million bucks,
because you guys infringe
on my free speech?"
Or is it just purely, just,
"Yeah, we screwed up,"
it's back up, and nobody gets
fired, this is the government?
- Well, we have been
suing the government.
The case I just
described is like that.
And in the Ninth Circuit,
I think we ran into a,
let's just say we haven't
received the ruling yet,
but it was not a favorable
reception in the Ninth Circuit.
I pray that in fact,
at the end of the day,
these Twitter files
actually started to come out
after the hearing.
And so maybe, you know,
the clerks and the judges
will see that wait, whoa,
this is actually a huge deal.
This isn't a one-off, this
is actually a whole system
that's been exposed.
A case like that, filed
in a different court,
might have succeeded,
but actually under
Twitter's terms of service,
you have to file it
here in California.
You know, so it's
been been a challenge.
I'm confident that over time,
there will be a case
that breaks through,
that says that this
is a violation of
the First Amendment.
I do think it is.
There are some First
Amendment lawyers who say,
"Oh no, the companies can
do whatever they want,
it was merely a strong
suggestion from the government."
- (laughing) Right, right.
- But here in the Twitter files,
Twitter was actually
being paid by the FBI.
I mean, I don't know
how you can deny
that that's government action.
It's government
action obviously.
So I'm sorry I'm very
animated about it,
but I'm shocked that judges
aren't picking this up.
- Right, well also if the
government was to call me,
if I got a call from
a government agent,
saying, "Dave, we're not
telling you to do anything,
but just FYI, we've
been watching the show,
and you've been saying
a lot about that,"
I might take that as a
threat, or some sort of order.
- Yeah, or-
- That's why
the gray area here, obviously,
is where the real stuff is.
- Right, I mean, or, you know,
nice social media presence,
and show you have,
shame if something
were to happen to it,
or you know, maybe
there's an audit.
You know, like
literally the government
has so much power over us,
we're seeing it with
January 6th stuff.
I mean, they can
crime and harass you.
And so this is
not trivial to me.
And by the way, I, as a
First Amendment lawyer,
I would stand up for the
rights of some leftist
to be able to say whatever
they want on social media,
short of threats of violence
that are true threats,
or other violations of
enumerated parts of 230,
pornography and
things like that.
But that does not
seem to be reciprocal.
The left has entirely abandoned
the principle of due process,
equal protection for
speech issues on the right.
The ACLU no longer
supports free speech.
They don't support you being
able to talk about gun use.
I mean, it is a
180, and it is just
a wholly awoke
woke endeavor now.
And so we, the right,
have become the
engine of free speech.
And even on our side,
people don't get it.
So I'd love to see a whole
revolution on our side
about these issues.
- Okay, so speaking
of a revolution,
now let's talk about
what your plans are
to do with the Republicans.
One of the lines that I say
on this show all the time
is you don't have
to be a Republican,
but you cannot be a Democrat.
And I think that's
really resonated
with an awful lot of people,
that the Democrats
have lost their mind,
The Republicans, it's messy,
they're gonna fail
you sometimes,
but at least there's
something there to work with.
So what would your vision be
of what the Republican
Party would truly stand for?
You hit on a little
bit of it earlier,
but what's the real vision that
you wanna sell to the party?
- Well, first of all, you
should be a Republican
if you're not a Democrat.
(Dave laughing)
You should not, I believe that,
let me just put
that on the table.
It is a zero sum game,
they're two parties
that are relevant
in this country.
And if you're not
winning, you're losing.
That's the fact
of politics, okay.
So with respect to what
I would do differently,
there, I mean we probably
don't even have time here,
but look, the party has
evolved in a certain direction.
It's really been the same
two people running it
for the last 12 years.
The base of the party
has changed in a revolutionary
way during those 12 years.
Some of the same staff
from the Reince Priebus
era of six years
are still running the
show at the RNC today.
And guess what those
staff are doing?
They're negotiating contracts
that are self-interested.
Hundreds of millions of dollars
has flown into the
pockets of consultants
over the last few years, and
we haven't won elections.
The Democrats don't
operate that way.
The Democrats smartened
up after losing elections
and paying a bunch of
money to consultants
almost 20 years ago.
And they said, "No, no, no,
we're not gonna
do that anymore."
The party will only do the stuff
that only the party can do.
And the party plays a
very important role.
They have certain role,
with respect to sharing
data with state parties,
with respect to fundraising,
with respect to, you know,
they have certain role,
but a lot of the
stuff the Democrats do
is outside the party.
They do it in nonprofits,
pseudo nonprofits,
PACs and whatever.
But still the messaging is
led by a party apparatus
that is disciplined on,
focused on messaging,
and on their goals.
They do not, you know, have
little disputes with each other
in the press, and members of
Congress attacking each other.
That just doesn't happen.
They have a party discipline,
and they ruthlessly
collect money
and dump it into our races.
And we sit here and say,
as a Republican Party,
"Uh oh, sorry, our rules say
we can't do anything
about that."
I'm not saying that the party
should be picking
candidates in the primary,
but what I am saying
is you're foolish
if you let the Democrats
pick your candidates
in the primary.
We have no plan for that.
The election laws were changed
on a wholesale basis in 2020,
increment for that.
Our party was not
raising or spending money
on election litigation.
We were like, "Oh, oh,
there's an election?
Let's have some itinerant,
you know, temp lawyers
put down their laptops and
work like a lawyer militia,
and work for free to save
elections for two weeks,
and then go back to their jobs."
It doesn't work that way, we
have jobs, we have commitments.
You can't just like make me
work for free for two weeks.
So we have to have
been investing like
the Democrats did,
in lawyers like Mark Elias,
who is funded to the tune
of whatever he wants,
and files frivolous
lawsuits sometimes,
and just spams the courts
with nonsense lawsuits.
But they get through and they
win if there's no opposition.
We have not been doing that
until the last two years.
I will say the
chair listened to me
jumping up and down
and screaming about it.
We began to invest in that
issue, we're still way behind.
Our cost of fundraising,
Dave, is out of control.
It's like 40%, okay.
I just came from a
Turning Point USA event,
Turning Points cost
of fundraising,
now it's a nonprofit, 7% or so?
They raise hundreds
of millions of dollars
over the same time
period that we have.
Where's that other 30%
going? What's going on there?
It's going into the
pockets of people
who are not helping
us win elections.
I'm very passionate about this.
Little donors, mom and pops,
people like my parents and
my, you know, other relatives,
they say, oh, "Lindsey
Graham needs money,
you know, let's give him
some money, I like him,
I saw him on television,"
and suddenly they're
like signed up forever
to keep getting emails
from every Republican
in the universe,
and they can't stop it.
The puppy will die, you know,
your mom will be held hostage.
Like the messages
are so abusive.
And then big dollar
donors are really sick
of giving their five
million, 10 million,
$50 million check, and
we don't win elections.
I mean that's not what
they're there for.
So pretty much nobody is
satisfied with the status quo,
except a significant percentage
of the members of the
Republican National Committee,
who have their power,
their privilege,
their title, their prestige,
their photographs
of politicians.
I'm not there for that,
I'm here to win elections,
so I can go back
and enjoy my life.
And so we would be
making one of the things
that really ratcheted up the
ugliness in this race, Dave,
it'll be very
interesting to know
that I think on day
three of my campaign,
I tweeted that I would
initiate a top to bottom audit
of every consulting and
vendor contract at the RNC.
And before that, it was a very
gentile exchange of ideas,
and isn't it cute that
Harmeet's running?
Suddenly every political
consultant in D.C.
is out for my blood,
placing hit pieces.
But it's all gonna come out,
it's all gonna come out
what's been going on there,
and then we can talk
about what we do about it,
because the Democrats don't have
this rotten, corrupt
system like we do.
And look, a lot of
people in our RNC,
most of them are well-meaning,
but they don't control
what's going on there.
And so I think, I've
had some conversations
with members who've been
shocked to hear what I've said,
and I think I changed their
minds, because you know,
it's a very top
down organization.
The RNC tells the states,
"If you want us to subsidize
a particular walk app or
method of fundraising, win red,
you have to use our
system, no choice.
We don't give you a choice
as to what works
better in your state."
That's not Republican.
The Republican is pushing
power down to the people,
it's respecting the people,
it's not calling them names.
Some of my fellow
members of the union
have called voters low
information bitchers
for daring to contact them
about this leadership race.
I love hearing
from those voters,
I don't call them names
like that, they're voters.
They may be angry,
sometimes they are,
but they're angry
for a good reason,
'cause they're Republicans,
and we don't win elections,
so of course they're
angry, I'm angry.
So I think it is with a
relatively simple platform
that I've been laying out,
as I'm talking to the
168, 167 other voters,
but I'm also sharing
that with the public.
And there is virtually
no support for the
current leadership
outside the RNC, and
the consultant class
who feed off of us, and
so that's been heartening.
And so one way or the other,
we're gonna see
change at the RNC.
- Right, I mean I agree
with the premise there.
It doesn't seem like there's
a lot of support there,
but for whatever reason,
and you people can
call it the swamp,
or the deep state, or
whatever the hell it is,
it does keep going.
So the outsiders, like you,
always have that uphill battle.
I see sort of two parts of this.
You're talking about sort
of the under the hood
technical stuff, like that
that are the problems,
in terms of voting and what's
going on with fundraising.
But I think there's
also the ideal level
that it seems like there's
a real problem brewing.
Just in the last couple days,
I heard Mitch McConnell say
that the number one issue
on Republican's minds
is defending
Ukraine from Russia.
And I thought, "Man," you know,
I'm, for the first
time in my life,
since I moved to Florida, I
registered as a Republican,
but I think the
ideas I talk about
resonate with a lot of
people on both sides,
it's like, that's
not in my top 20.
And the way he said it-
- Right.
- I thought, "Man, I can
now see why Republican,
you know, the OG Republicans
have just had it with you guys."
What do you do about
the messaging part
that seems very disconnected,
when he could be talking
about, I don't know,
the economy, the border,
free speech, et cetera?
- Well, I can't do anything
about Mitch McConnell.
If I were in the
United States Senate,
I'd be voting for
a different leader.
I can't do anything
about the leadership race
in the House, where because
we didn't do that well,
there was no red wave.
You have this infighting
that's just awful.
Friends of mine are throwing
stones at each other.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Unfortunate.
But I can do something
about the RNC,
and the RNC does
set the messaging.
And unfortunately we've
been kind of hostage
to whatever happened recently,
whatever the Democrats
said recently,
we're always like
reacting to that.
We don't seem to be going
back to our platform,
or our basic values,
or frankly even taking a poll,
and then talking about what
Republicans actually care about.
We spend millions, during
this chair's tenure,
there have been millions
of dollars spent
on consultants, on messaging
issues, believe it or not.
And what you see is
the result of that.
It's not very good
messaging, I'm sorry to say,
sorry to offend the people
who are probably
gonna be very angry,
and set out more hit pieces
about me because of that,
but it's true.
Our base does not
like or appeal,
the messaging did
not turn out voters.
The candidates did
not turn out voters,
and we sat there
like sitting ducks,
spending a bunch
of money on them.
And you know, some of
these, like I said,
back to the issue left
to find our candidates,
we're letting that happen
because we're not doing a
good job of picking them
and defining them.
There's no party.
Maybe there needs to be more
of a like cabal situation,
where you get together
and say, "Look guys,
we're not gonna win in Georgia,
and we're not gonna
win in Pennsylvania.
We're not gonna win in
this state or that state
if we don't have a candidate
who fits this profile."
That means our data
has to be good.
Our messaging has to be good.
We have to have enough money,
and we have to be doing
litigation around the clock.
Election integrity is not a
seasonal itinerate worker deal.
I mean, you know,
the RNC has laid off
most of its election integrity
staff after the election,
as if they're like, we picked
the crop, and now we're done.
(Dave laughing)
No, no, no,
we need to be doing, we
are so far behind the left,
we need to be doing this
for a decade or two,
until we reverse the tide.
And we need to be spending
10X what we're spending on it.
- Does it seem sort of
too black-pilled to you
when people say, "Well
look, you've got California,
the most populous
state in the union,
and it's one party
at this point,
and it's over, and
it's corrupt, we know.
Just kinda let it be."
I mean, I tried, I tried, I
could not take it anymore.
I don't know if you know
this, by the way, Harmeet,
three days after
the recall election,
that obviously I was
helping Larry Elder with,
I was audited by the state,
coincidentally the same
day that I sold my house,
or put my house for sale.
But what do you say to that?
Like, the people
that are just like,
"No, we just have to
concede the ground
of some of these states,
'cause the machinery
is so entrenched."
- Well, I can see the
ocean from my home,
and that's why I
live in California.
(Dave laughing)
- And can't do that in-
- We got an ocean
here in Florida, you know.
It's a different ocean-
- I know.
- But it's pretty good.
- You know, the Pacific
is more beautiful.
Florida's great too, but I
don't like those giant bugs
you have over there.
But seriously,
no, we cannot seat
any part of America to the left.
And look, I mean those of
us who didn't get the memo
were still like fighting
behind enemy lines here,
like it was World War II.
I mean, we were told
the war was over.
Some of us are still
fighting that war here.
We picked up seats in
the House in California,
old fashioned work.
John Duarte, I raised
$100,000 for John Duarte,
our new member of
Congress in California.
Hey, you know, he is
from a farming community,
he's a farming, he's a farmer.
Go figure, you know,
you picked a candidate
who's like the district,
and he's a good communicator
who's authentic.
He had the money,
'cause people like me,
and others helped
him raise the money.
But the RNC did
invest in California
to help in targeted districts.
And we, the party of California,
pulled that off, okay.
So I think there
are a lot of factors
that contributed to that.
That's good, because we
went from 14 seats in 2016
to seven seats in 2018.
My god, that was a wipe out,
and then we've
slowly built back,
even as we've lost a
congressional seat.
So no, it's not hopeless.
But I mean the recall
was kind of sad.
Larry Elder was a dynamic
candidate, and all of that.
Getting your campaign
started at the last minute,
and never having run
for office before,
and the first thing you
run for, advocate for that.
I definitely think that
people should learn the ropes.
We've been encouraging
people here in California,
in this election cycle, to step
up and run for school board.
Are you a mom or a dad, you're
upset with what's going on?
School board is not very
expensive to run for,
it's easy to campaign for, it's
a small universe of voters,
and we had some
success in that regard.
We have to be training
people to do that.
I've run for office twice.
Unlike the current chair, I
actually know what it means
to actually like,
stand out there,
put your money
where your mouth is,
and actually stand at the
BART, the subway station,
hand out cards, talk to
hostile groups of people,
raise money from strangers.
It's a skillset that
you cannot just get
'cause you have great ideas.
It is a craft, everyone.
So I think it, I think
that we need to have,
and we had another
good candidate,
the mayor of San Diego,
and you know, once Larry came
in, who was very popular,
that was just, that
race was just over.
But I don't think Larry had
built the team necessary to win.
And so George Gascon recall,
okay, in Los Angeles,
that should have succeeded.
I believe it bungled
because of consultants.
Consultants, who did
the signature gathering,
did not do their jobs correctly,
and there was no
transparency around that,
and now it's degenerated
into investigations
and all of that, what a tragedy.
But here in San Francisco,
in a liberal city,
we got rid of the school board,
and we got rid of our
district attorney.
So there is a point at
which even liberals,
even even $12 avocado
toast-eating liberals
will say, "No more,
I don't want feces
in front of my hip
loft condo, I'm done."
So yes, I do think that
that they're persuadable.
- Yeah, George Gascon,
who you mentioned,
just for people that don't know,
he's the former DA
of San Francisco,
who ruined San Francisco,
then moved down to LA.
Bernie backed, of course,
basically ruined LA, and then
the recall against him fell.
But as you referenced,
the recall of Boudin
in San Francisco,
that one actually worked.
Have you seen any
changes in San Francisco?
Is there any chance that
because they got rid of
some of these guys,
and have, I suppose,
slightly less crazed lefties,
that things are
gonna get better?
- I would call, I would
describe it as a marginal change
but the rep from the
DA is much better.
She's talking about
prosecuting crimes,
she is prosecuting crimes.
I don't think we're gonna,
I mean, at the depth
of, earlier this year,
Chesa Boudin's tenure,
elderly Asians were
regularly getting stabbed,
assaulted, knocked over,
killed, with no prosecution.
That's not happening anymore.
I haven't read a
single story like that
since Brooke Jenkins became
the district attorney.
She's probably a
Democrat, I don't know,
it's a nonpartisan race, but
whatever, I voted for her,
because, you know,
she was the person
who was most likely to
succeed, and I live here.
And so it matters to
me, it's, you know,
I have to call the
police sometimes
over threats that
are made to me.
I really want there to
be a district attorney
who cares about that stuff.
So I think she's an improvement.
Could we, would I
one day like to vote
for a Republican for that race?
Absolutely, but you know,
I'll take a better Democrat
where that's the only choice.
So I think that's
a good development.
Now we have to keep it up.
But San Francisco
has been absolute,
that's not the point
of your question,
but this city is so
hollowed out and decimated
by the combination of COVID
lockdowns, work from home,
Twitter and other big companies
packing up and leaving.
It is not the same
city as it was.
And so yes, in a
Detroit-type situation,
where people are leaving
abandoned houses, and stuff,
and yes, you do see a
certain level of, you know,
the most unfortunate of
society wandering the streets.
And some of them
are mentally ill,
many of them are using
drugs, and it is dangerous.
I don't walk to work anymore
like I used to in San Francisco.
So how long I'm able
to put up with this
is an open question
in our household.
- Yeah, the last time
I was in San Francisco
was literally the day they
were announcing lockdowns
for the first time.
I was there to raise
money for locals,
on the day that the
market was crashing.
And I felt being
in San Francisco
was sort of a metaphor for that.
But, all right, so let's
move then from that coast,
to where I am in Florida,
where now obviously
DeSantis wins by 20 points.
He's got a, the Republicans
have super majority,
there's basically
everything is working here.
Do you view what's
going on here,
election integrity,
which is working,
do you view this
experiment here in Florida
as sort of the blueprint
of what you could export
throughout the country?
- Well, I mean I certainly
am very impressed
with what's happened in
Florida, it is truly impressive.
And even with early
voting, they mastered it.
You know, the RNC
really has not.
I saw the chair yesterday
claiming credit for,
"Oh, we did this, we did that."
And in fact, you know, it's
really state leadership
that makes it happen.
The RNC may provide
financial resources,
but it hasn't really provided
the training to do that.
Yeah, I wish I could live
in a utopian, you know,
Republican paradise,
like Florida,
with the tax rates
and the, you know,
the wonderful non
lockdown situation.
But I wish that was
California. (laughing)
But yes, I think
it's very impressive,
and leadership does matter,
and so Republicans can
efficiently run a state,
and bring it back, it's
been very impressive.
- Where do the presidential,
or potential presidential
candidates of '24,
what kind of role
do they play in,
I guess what you're doing now,
and what you would be doing if
you actually win this thing?
Because obviously there's really
two things happening here.
There's the Trump
portion of this,
and then there's this
either maybe DeSantis thing,
or just something
that is not Trump.
How does that factor in to
what you're doing right now,
and then what you would do
as the potential
head of this thing?
- So President Trump selected
Ronna Romney McDaniel
to become the chair in 2016,
when Reince Priebus
went to the White House
as his chief of staff.
Some of the RNC staff
went to the White House,
and then some of them were
let go, for various reasons,
and they went back to the RNC.
So it's basically
been the same folks
running the show over there.
President Trump
endorsed Ronna in 2018,
after we had a
disastrous election,
and again in 2020 after
he lost the White House.
So he has not weighed in on
this election cycle as yet.
Although I saw a report
in the Associated Press
a couple of days
ago that, you know,
one of his top advisors
is quietly telling people
he's supporting the current
leadership for a fourth term.
So, I mean, I'm one of
President Trump's lawyers,
and my law firm represents,
my partner's represent him
in several other matters,
besides what I've done.
So I'm not gonna change what
I'm doing based on that.
This is something that
comes from my heart to do.
It isn't based on a
particular candidate
telling me what to do.
So, and I don't
think it's, you know,
appropriate for a
candidate for this position
to seek the endorsement of
a presidential candidate,
because the RNC is meant to
be neutral on these issues.
So that is my
commitment to voters,
'cause we have people on
both sides in the RNC.
We have a lot of
Trump supporters.
I was a two-time Trump voter.
And then we have some people
who are also two-time
Trump voters,
who wanna see
something different.
And so, you know,
the voters in America
are gonna decide that,
I'm not gonna decide it.
So I don't think any
of the other candidates
have weighed in formally,
and that's okay,
because I think that, you
know, we really need to see
what Republicans and
the grassroots want.
This isn't a top-down party,
in my opinion, it should not be.
And so I very much
hope that we have
a grassroots-oriented
outcome to this election.
- What's the technical part of
how you get elected actually?
- We have a-
- Like how does the leader
actually get elected?
- Yeah, we have a winter
meeting of the RNC
in Dana Point, California,
and there are 168 voters.
There're 50 states,
and six territories.
Each of them has three members,
a national committee man,
a national committee woman,
and a chair of the party.
And so you have to, you
know, you have to lobby
with each of those.
Now if you're the chair, you
can cut deals with people
based on resources
that you have.
That's just a fact, some
members are very upset
that I said that at the
beginning of my campaign,
Hey, guess what?
Some of them are shocked,
shocked to find out
that politics is happening
in this establishment.
Yeah, that's politics.
Yeah, you scratch my
back, I'll scratch yours.
You change your vote
from Bob to Sue,
and I'll make sure you're
the head of that committee.
That happens at the RNC
since the beginning of time.
But I don't have
that ability, right,
'cause I'm not able
to hand out goodies.
So that's, but I have my ideas.
I have millions of
Republican voters
who want to see a
change at the RNC,
and ultimately the
members of the RNC
are gonna have to
face reelection, or
election themselves.
And there's gonna be a question
as to who did you support in
the 2022, 2023 leadership race?
And so people are
publicly committed
to the current share,
before I entered the race.
I mean, she had
committed, as I mentioned,
to running only
for a third term,
and she said she
was out after that.
So it was kind of a
shocker to see her come out
with this long list of
supporters, but whatever,
I'm not deterred.
I think it's gonna
go down to the wire.
We have major donors
calling me, cold calling me,
I've never spoken
to them before.
Members of Congress,
United States Senators,
and certainly some
members of the RNC,
who called me before
I called them,
saying, "Thank God
you're running,
we really need a
change, I support you.
How can I help you?"
So it's been pretty encouraging.
- Yeah, for the record, I'd
be happy to have Ronna on,
and I would treat her the exact
same way I'm treating you,
and ask the same type
of questions, and
all of that stuff.
What do you think
the argument is?
What is her main argument?
I mean, because we all thought
this red wave was coming,
and then it didn't come, and
they barely got the House.
So it's like where
is the argument
that you should stick
around for this,
as you described
this fourth term,
that was never supposed to be?
- Yeah.
- I'm really making
you be a lawyer now.
- Yes, well, I am
an ethical person,
so I will present this
being said by her team,
which is, she did a great job.
Four million more
Republicans turned out
than in the prior cycle.
We won back some seats
in different states,
she's taken credit for that,
she's taken credit for
the wins in Florida,
New York, and California.
I, you know, I think everyone
who lives in those states
can make up their
own mind about that.
I will leave it at that,
trying to be polite.
People like her, personally,
and I don't dislike her.
I'm not running against her
because of her personality.
And you know, quote unquote,
I did a lot for your state.
That's really what
I'm hearing back.
I transferred X
dollars, to your state.
I've offered to pay this,
I offered to pay that.
Some of it is transactional,
some of it is relationship,
and some of it is
so-called loyalty.
Some of it is, I
asked you first.
I mean, then one argument is,
we shouldn't change horses
in the middle of the race.
I mean, what's the race here?
Like racing off a cliff,
as far as I can tell,
we should definitely
change horses.
Sailing analogy
is, I'm a sailor,
is, you know, if you're
heading for the rocks,
you should definitely
correct course.
Maybe you need to reef the sails
if there's a storm happening,
and you need to like
definitely, you know,
pull in some of those sail,
so you don't, you know, crash.
And I think that's, you know,
so that's the counter argument.
But you asked me to
say what she's saying,
"Yeah, steady, I've
done a great job,
we should not change the course.
We're already planning for
this convention and you know,
we're doing great,"
that's the message.
- Do you actually
think that the DNC
is not as screwed
up and all the stuff
that you just expressed
frustration with,
and how deals get done
and all that stuff,
that the DNC is not as screwy,
or are they just better
at the screwiness?
You know, like if you were
to look at the FTX situation,
it's like they got all
the money, basically,
I know he also gave
some to Republicans,
but he was the second,
Sam Bankman-Fried,
was second largest
donor to Democrats.
And then of course two
days after the election,
it all comes crashing down,
meaning that they're
just somehow better
at the public show,
and then we just move on,
and you forget about
all the corruption,
something like that?
- So the Democrats
are definitely not
as screwy as we are,
and I think they're not
screwy at all, actually,
in the Democratic Party.
They raise money in a
very disciplined way.
And you know, they do
have their little tiffs,
personality tiffs between
the squad and Nancy Pelosi.
But overall I think
they're very disciplined.
And now for the first couple
of years I was at the RNC,
we would be cheering, "Rah rah,"
because we raised more
money into the RNC
than the DNC raises
into the DNC.
And they're quietly laughing,
because they raised 10 times
as much money as we do,
but they raise it into
the NAACP, and the ACLU,
and the Michigan Welfare
Rights Association,
and La Raza, and
La Familia Vota.
Those five organizations
are organizations
that I'm up against
in court right now
for election litigation.
That's not the DNC.
They have dark
money organizations
that influence our elections,
and help pick right
wing candidates in
moderate districts.
And so that we just
like, we are cooked.
We're thinking,
"Great, we selected
this great conservative
candidate,"
that candidate can't
win in that state.
And so we're just like not
even talking about that.
So their monetary ecosystem
is far superior to ours,
and they're very
disciplined, and we are not,
and we need to get smart.
- All right, gimme
your final pitch,
and where do you wanna send
people to find out more?
- @PNJABAN on
Twitter is my handle.
And then for my campaign,
dhillonforrnc.com,
D-H-I-L-L-O-N-F-O-R-R-N-C.com
And you know, please,
if you are interested
in supporting us,
reach out politely
to the three members
of the RNC in your district,
do not call them names.
Some of them are very
shocked to hear from voters.
And importantly, if you're
a precinct committee man,
or a state party delegate,
and you play a role
in a state party,
call for a vote of who should
be the next leader of the RNC.
That happened in
Texas and Arizona,
and a standing
vote in Tennessee,
and they all support
overwhelmingly,
and so that's been happening
all over the country.
- Harmeet, I obviously
wish you a lot of luck.
I also wish you merry
Christmas, and we shall see.
- Absolutely, thanks
for having me, Dave.
- My pleasure.
If you're looking
for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about politics,
instead of mindless dribble,
check out our politics playlist.
And if you wanna
watch full interviews
on a variety of topics, watch
our full episode playlist,
all right over here.
And to get notified
of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe, and
click the notification bell.